perturbations limitées aujourd'hui dans
les transports les forces et
l'électricité à l'appel de la cgt
nouvelle journée d'action dans les
secteurs public et privé jolie ouverture
de la discussion budgétaire à
l'assemblée pierre bérégovoy appelle à
nouveau les salariés à la sagesse
edouard balladur est l'invité de ce
journal les embarras de la rentrée
universitaire l'exemple de nanterre deux
fois plus d'étudiants que deux places le
prix nobel d'économie et français
maurice allais spécialiste de l'analyse
monétaire
sacrilège tour de force on a entendu ce
soir à londres une dixième symphonie de
beethoven qui n'en avait joué que neuf
madame monsieur bonsoir déception ou
durcissement dans les rangs de la cgt le
syndicat a décidé de se joindre jeudi à
la grève nationale décidée par les six
autres fédérations de fonctionnaires
c'est ce qu'a annoncé ce soir henri
krasucki au terme de la journée d'action
de la confédération qui a provoqué des
perturbations gênante bien sûr mais
plutôt imité dans divers secteurs à
commencer par les transports en commun
fbt nique à l'ajax
c'est ce soir en quittant leur travail
que les parisiens les banlieusards ont
eu à connaître les conséquences de la
grève le trafic a brutalement chuté à
partir de 18 heures de nombreux agents
de conduite ayant choisi de faire grève
deux heures seulement à la fin de leur
service au lieu du mouvement de 24
heures auxquelles avaient appelé la cgt
ce matin au contraire à paris les
autobus circulaient presque normalement
le réseau du métro est celui du rer
était très peu touché ailleurs en france
les transports urbains ont peu subi de
perturbations
hormis à marseille et à montpellier où
le mouvement était un peu plus suivi les
grandes lignes sncf ont fonctionné
normalement sauf au départ des gares
montparnasse et saint lazare qui ont vu
partir deux trains sur trois enfin aller
df quelques coupures d'électricité
tournantes ce matin mais les délestages
plus important prévu pour ce soir n'ont
finalement pas eu lieu
l'appel à la grève semble donc avoir été
suivis de façon modérée
ce n'est pas l'avis de la cgt qui
n'entend pas s'arrêter à cette journée
du 18 octobre vise 8
c'est tellement que 19 soit une
continuation et le prépare un vin la
plus grande puissance possible et 1,21
et légion suivant et toute la période
qui vient parce que les travailleurs ont
besoin d'être rassemblée d'agir pour se
faire entendre pour imposer enfin de
véritables négociations qui débouche sur
de véritables solutions
la cgt qui manifestaient ce matin à
paris en province appelle ses
fédérations à rejoindre les autres
syndicats de fonctionnaires dans leur
journée d'action d'après demain jeudi
cette journée n'était donc un avant goût
de ce qui nous attend jeudi jeudi jour
de grève générale des fonctionnaires
auxquels se joindront les personnels
d'air france la direction précise déjà
que les moyens courriers seront
perturbés mais koné long courriers
seront assurés
je n'ai pas dans les mains de quoi vous
satisfaire vous demandez trop d'un seul
coup voilà ce que le président
mitterrand a dit en substance tout à
l'heure à une délégation d'infirmières
en grève
il a rencontré à gaillon dans l'eure des
propos qui en valeur de soutien au
premier ministre et à sa politique
le chef de l'état inaugurait à gaillon
une statue de pierre mendès-france
accrue hommage a été rendu
c'était un homme d'état décidé à ne pas
céder sur l'essentiel a souligné
monsieur mitterrand ne pas céder sur
l'essentiel de leurs revendications
c'est évidemment le problème des
infirmières qui ensemble vous savez
alors
troisième semaine de grève quelques
signes d'effritement a signalé en
province à rennes et dans la sarthe où
le mouvement a été levé aujourd'hui si
les syndicats ont du mal depuis le début
à endiguer un mouvement qu'il ne
contrôle pas la coordination majoritaire
à la base est en prend maintenant à des
tiraillements internes
l'enquète de françoise joly d'une seule
et même voix
elle criait samedi au panthéon leur
force et leur unité leur force c'est
cette coordination en marge des
syndicats ou les infirmières se sont
retrouvés ensemble syndiqués et non
syndiqués
nous sommes là bas que nous vivons
quotidiennement les difficultés de la
profession et que je crois que de la
part de certaines organisations
syndicales pour beaucoup ce sont des
bureaucrates qui n'ont plus tellement
les pieds sur le terrain et qui peuvent
qui peuvent pas réellement assimiler le
problème réel de l'infirmière au niveau
des syndicats les gens qui sont venus me
voir par exemple pour adhérer à tel ou
tel syndicat c'était avant tout vendre
une carte c'était pas le dialogue je
crois que c'est le manque de dialogue
quelques pas alors elles ont pris la
parole comme nicole v navy 33 ans
cette infirmière non syndiqués et un des
leaders de la coordination
elle représente la base du mouvement et
c'est au nom de cette base qu
aujourd'hui nicole ne parle plus d'unité
au sein de la coordination elle craint
la récupération selon affaire à une
partie d'une tendance du bureau qui a
une formation politique certainement une
formation syndicale aussi et c'est vrai
que nous non syndiqués ou non associé
nous n'avons pas le même discours ce
niveau là nous conte défense et des
propositions catégorie side si les
revendications catégorielles
alors que l'autre tendance serait
d'élargir le mouvement à d'autres
catégories pas seulement de la santé cet
autre tendance qui le élargir le
mouvement est représenté par un autre
leader de la coordination pascal dias
infirmiers syndiqués et militants de la
ligue communiste révolutionnaire le
débat il est tactique sur est ce qu'on a
besoin de l'aide des autres catégories
qui avaient l'option besoin de notre
aide pour toute façon au pénal gamme
cross où est ce qu'on pense pouvoir
gagner tout seul donc le débat il est là
ces débats au sein de la coordination
infirmières sont révélateurs ce soir
d'un mouvement qui cherche un second
souffle et cela au moment où certains
hôpitaux comme par exemple rennes le
mans est doué suspendre la grève
le ministère de la santé invite
officiellement les syndicats à signer un
protocole d'accord vendredi prochain sur
la base des dernières propositions du
gouvernement
déjà la cgt fait savoir qu'elle ne
signera pas mais force ouvrière et la
cfdt pourrait l'accepter ce qui
accélérerait espère-t-on à matignon
l'effritement du mouvement avant les
manifestations que la coordination elle
prépare pour samedi prochain
coup d'envoi à l'assemblée nationale de
la discussion générale du budget le
ministre d'état en charge de l'économie
et des finances pierre bérégovoy a dans
son préambule insisté sur les vertus de
la rigueur
les différents partis ont commencé cet
après midi à donner leur point de vue
comme l'expliquent pascal guimier rien
et trompeurs comme ce palais bourbon
ravalée de 9 colbert grand argentier en
son temps semble de marbre il n'est
pourtant pétri que de résine de même à
l'intérieur à l'abri des intempéries
sociale les débats ont beau se suivre il
doit se ressemblent guère sur le revenu
minimum tout le monde ou presque était
d'accord et les sols vraie réticence
venait du ps en revanche sur le budget
les socialistes sont aujourd'hui les
seuls à marcher du même pas que le
gouvernement plus de justice pour les
petits contribuables un impôt sur la
fortune élargit en fait des retouches
qui n'altère pas le projet du ministre
un ministre qui plaide la bonne volonté
face un budget en partie héritée de la
gestion chirac mais un ministre surtout
qui à son tour s'emploie à apaiser les
conflits prend l'engagement de maintenir
le pouvoir d'achat et de l'améliorer
partout c'est possible et en particulier
pour les bas revenus mais je dis qu'il
ne faut pas compromettre le redressement
engagé en 1982 au moment où il porte ses
fruits
l'opposition se refuse à jeter de
l'huile sur le feu
concentrant ses attaques sur le sol
budget on décide pas assez d'europe
un effort insuffisant vers les
entreprises copine à refaire quant aux
communistes à ces critiques il ne
devrait pas voter contre
sans aller jusqu'à voter pour les débats
devraient garder de leur sérénité au
moins jusqu'à l'examen de l'impôt sur la
fortune
devenu article 18 du budget c'est alors
que commencera vraiment la bataille
politique
monsieur maladie en bon soir quand vous
voyez ainsi votre successeur au coeur de
l'hémicycle n'avait pas un petit frisson
nostalgie non pas du tout pas du tout
faut prendre la vie comme elle est et
les changements qu'il faut changer avec
elle alors ses budgets que monsieur
vergoz a donc commencé à défendre au
fond à part l'impôt sur les grandes
fortunes
vous ne l'auriez pas véritablement
renier tout à fait je leur ai tout à
fait régner madame il est tout à fait
contraire à ce que j'aurais souhaité
faire nous avons une très grande chance
c'est moi si c'est que la france est en
bonne situation
l'expansion est bonne l'activité
s'accroît
le chômage est stable l'inflation est
bien tenu des entreprises investissent
et du coup il ya beaucoup de rentrées
fiscales plus de 40 milliards de
rentrées fiscales supplémentaires en
1988 et 90 milliards de rentrées
fiscales de plus en 1989 en 1988 et bien
je trouve pour me résumer que le budget
qui nous est proposé n'en font pas mme
n'en fait pas bon usage que les dépenses
augmentent trop et que le déficit n'est
pas assez réduit et que les impôts ne
sont pas assez diminué voilà mon
jugement global sur ce budget non vous
allez voter contre
je vais voter contre certainement sauf
si le gouvernement acceptait de l'amendé
de façon tout à fait fondamentale j'ai
peine à l'imaginer
alors simone veil raymond barre et
aujourd'hui pierre méhaignerie ont
approuvé le souci du premier ministre et
des ministres d'état en matière de
salaires est-ce que sur ce plan là en
tout cas vous apporteriez aussi votre
soutien cette politique de fermeté sur
le front des revendications salariales
voilà ce que je voudrais dire ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui dans une certaine
mesure la conséquence des propos qui ont
été tenus il ya quelques mois par des
responsables du gouvernement indiquant
que le temps du partage était arrivé et
tout se passe comme si vraiment nous
étions au terme de nos efforts que la
france se portait très bien et qu'on
pouvait donc distribuer davantage mais
ce n'est pas ce que l'on entend non je
crois que c'est au contraire contraire à
la vérité parce que nous avons encore
beaucoup d'efforts à faire et que nous
sommes encore le pays d'europe qui a le
plus fort taux de chômage parmi les
grands pays européens et que donc pour
réduire le chômage qui est l'objectif
fondamental il faut absolument que les
entreprises puissent produire un
meilleur prix pour créer des emplois
mais là vous parlait pratiquement comme
le premier ministre ait interféré donné
mais parfaitement sur ce plan là tout à
fait mais mais je dirais que c'est pas
uniquement une question matérielle
madame est d'ailleurs quelqu'un tout à
l'heure dans le reportage que vous avez
montré à parler de dialogue
je crois que ce qui est nécessaire en ce
moment aux hommes et aux femmes ce n'est
pas uniquement les satisfactions
matérielles
c'est le désir d'être reconnu dans sa
dignité dans sa responsabilité dans son
autonomie de se voir parler comme un
égal et ses dialogues vous avez
sentiments vous monsieur balladur de
l'avoir instauré quand justement bas
quand vous m'avez un interrompue
j'allais dire que nous avons nous mêmes
faits l'épreuve et subi l'épreuve des
conséquences que peut avoir ce niveau de
la grève la sncf qui a deux ans et de la
grève dans les services publics mais un
dialogue insuffisant autrement dit un
peu le progrès social ces deux choses à
la fois c'est à la fois les
satisfactions matérielles mais c'est
aussi mais c'est aussi la reconnaisse la
reconnaissance de dignité de chacun qui
passe par le dialogue et qui passe par
la participation donc à la fois un culte
à et un conseiller au gouvernement quel
os oui je crois qu'il faut faire très
attention à tous les aspects
psychologiques et moraux de la condition
de tous ceux qui travaillent ça compte
beaucoup plus qu'on ne le croit
j'ai été chef d'entreprise disant je
sais ce dont je parle c'est une chose
extrêmement
un dernier point monsieur balaté êtes
vous préoccupé par l'état du franc ces
temps-ci l'état du franc dépend de toute
une série d'éléments dont les uns
tiennent à la politique française est on
dans les autres sont indépendants de la
politique française actuellement il me
semble qu'ils sont plutôt indépendant de
la politique française le dollar baisse
le marque monte donc le franc est un
petit peu mis en cause
je suis tout à fait partisan d'un franc
solide et d'un franc fort mais je dis
que ça ne peut résulter que d'une bonne
politique économique et que notamment il
est très important pour susciter la
confiance que le budget soit géré avec
beaucoup de soin et avec beaucoup de
prudence
monsieur balladur merci en tout cas pour
la deuxième fois en deux mois la banque
de france vient de donner un coup de
pouce pour soutenir le franc son taux
d'intervention sur le marché monétaire a
été relevé d'un quart de point à 7 25 %
les taux augmentent quand c'est
nécessaire il faut être pragmatique
lorsque la solidité du franc est en jeu
a déclaré pierre bérégovoy qui voulait
au départ vous en souvenez les baisser
monsieur bérégovoy sera demain matin
l'invité de gérard morin aux 4 vérités
la rentrée universitaire se poursuit
selon les académies mais non sans tracas
ni embarras souvent il y a trop
d'étudiants pas assez d'enseignement et
tout le monde est à l'étroit reprenant
l'exemple de nanterre là les chiffres
parlent d'eux mêmes il ya vingt-huit
mille étudiants pour seize mille places
sur je me serais daniel levy renom vu
concrètement les effets 1 ampère la
première agression c'est la foule
anne est en deuxième année de droit sa
journée commence à 8 heures une journée
marathon où il faut sens à jouer des
coudes
avoir sa place
voilà à nanterre c'est ça l'important on
a ici et là que tout le temps là que
l'administration fait tout ce qu'elle
peut pour gérer une situation de plus en
plus critique une fac de 28 mille
étudiants prévue pour 16 mille espace
qui est un manque d'information
totalement de la formation obligation de
revenir de refaire accueille donc de re
loupé d'autres courent c'est sérieux
problème il manque 200 professeurs pour
une faculté d'environ 800 enseignants
que ce soir les inscriptions les salles
sont trop petites les groupes sont trop
nombreux il n'y a pas assez proche on
n'a pas de moyens on peut même pas faire
une photocopie
c'est sous c'est comme ça 10h30 du matin
c'est la ruée vers le grand amphi
prévu pour 1000 places en économie les
étudiants s'y retrouvent à 12 cents
voire 15 sans parler d'instruction est
alors un euphémisme il est connu que la
france est un des pays qui consacre le
moins en terme de moyens financiers aux
étudiants le court que j'assure est une
illustration peut être un peu poussé
mais l'illustration de cette situation
travaux dirigés à 50 au lieu de 30 des
horaires de cours jusqu'à 10 heures du
soir pour absorber le trop plein le
résultat le voici
mais moi j'arrive ici à 8 heures et je
repars à 9 heures du soir alors que la
journée j'ai des trous de 5 à 6 heures
comment vous gérer tout ça commence
aujourd'hui moi c'est pareil j'habite à
60 km et puis on vient pour 8 heures
jusqu'à neuf heures du soir alors bon
est-ce qu'on peut réussir à nanterre ou
bien sûr qu'on peut réussir sans que
réussir partout à quelle condition
d'être plus qu un bosseur et
voire plus que les autres et pourtant
elle tourne cette université est plutôt
bien côté les expériences de pointe
apprentissage des affaires dans la
langue du pays
des rapports étroits avec les
entreprises chaque année ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il ya de plus en plus
d'étudiants qui viennent nous voir pour
travailler dans les associations et
notamment la junior-entreprise oublier
le côté spectaculaire nanterre n'est pas
une exception elle tient debout grâce à
son personnel ses professeurs pour
combien de temps les repères dans un
communiqué aujourd'hui c'était une des
conditions de la rentrée universitaire
et du silence du ministre de l'éducation
nationale
trois semaines tout juste c'est dans 3
semaines que les électeurs américains
auront à choisir leur prochain président
le républicain george bush qui à la
corde avec 17 points d'avance selon le
dernier sondage
michael dukakis le démocrate et c'est
d'affiner sa tactique est aussi d'éviter
le découragement
jacquat bouchard dans l'entourage de
michael dukakis ce n'est pas encore la
panique mais à trois semaines du jour j
un vent de défaitisme souffle sur l'état
major démocrate
al'inverse george bush doit contenir
l'euphorie de ses partisans qui sentent
la victoire à portée de main tout a
basculé après le débat de la semaine
dernière les sondages se sont envolés 13
points d'avance pour bush
aujourd'hui on en est à 17 points
manifestement michael dukakis a raté sa
cible et la bataille s'est intensifiée
par le biais de la publicité à la
télévision arme de choc des deux
candidats
exemples de messages anti du kaki des
criminels sont libérés sans purgé leur
peine pour illustrer le laxisme reproché
au candidat démocrate menait ses
personnages hilares tourner en dérision
les milliards de dollars de dettes
accumulées par les états unis
pendant les huit années de
l'administration reagan c'est une pub
ont le dos au mur michael dukakis est en
train de changer de stratégie
à la télévision il durcit le ton de ce
message sur le terrain il concentre son
action sur une vingtaine d'états surtout
industrielle
il aurait fait une croix sur le sud y
compris le texas où les sondages qui
sont très défavorables
malgré les efforts déployés par son
colistier lloyd benson lui-même un natif
du texas
quelles que soient les offres des
candidats un homme triomphe le président
reagan
non seulement il jouit d'une cote de
popularité sans précédent au terme d'un
second mandat
mais il a eu raison contre toutes
attentes des économistes qui lie à un
henry kahn est ouvertement de ces propos
vous en souvenez simple correction
technique avait il dit en commentant la
chute vertigineuse de la bourse de new
york qui le 19 octobre 1987 semblait
annoncer un krach mondial
et bien un an plus tard la croissance
reste forte et les bourses ont dans leur
ensemble repris de la vigueur
comme l'a constaté à paris véronique
auger même s'il ya eu bien sûr des
perdants pourquoi ne pas fêter
l'événement au champagne
la bourse de paris grimpe c'est même la
place financière la plus recherchée
après gross très regardé les indices en
bas de ces deux tableaux 146 aujourd'hui
92 il ya juste un an
paris a fait plus que récupérer son
argent depuis neuf mois les actions ont
réalisé 52 % de hausse
quelqu'un qui aurait eu dans son
portefeuille tout les privatiser dans
les quantités imposée par la loi aurait
gagné 29 % moralité il ne fallait pas
vendre
il y avait deux catégories une catégorie
qui n'est pas très important
d'épargnants qui ont été balayés parce
qu'il venait en boucle pour essayer de
gratter les derniers et la dernière
hausse de la bourse et qui venait
uniquement spéculation par contre tous
les autres petits épargnants qui étaient
motivés plus profondément motivés sont
restés et certains ont même renforcé
profiter de la baisse et d'autres sont
rentrés en france était abondamment pour
entrer les épargnants tremble malgré
tout désormais il tapisse leurs
portefeuilles d'obligations des titres
de père de famille
quant aux petits spéculateurs il s'amuse
de nouveau comme des fous ils parient
sur leur achat brutal d'entreprise en
bourse
il n'y croit gagner sur les rumeurs de
paix a depuis neuf mois
quarante sociétés ont été attaqués par
des readers enfin un économiste français
récompensé par le nobel c'est le premier
son nom maurice allais il a 77 ans il
enseigne à l'école nationale supérieure
des mines à paris spécialiste des
phénomènes monétaire dans l'économie de
marché
il a décidé de sa carrière en étudiant
le krach de 1929 et il avait prédit
celui de 1987
claire chazal la rencontre est tout à
l'heure maurice allais ne s'y attendait
plus
on avait si souvent promis le nobel à ce
polytechnicien sorti du rang de 77 ans
dans les plus grands économistes
français ont été les élèves
il faut dire que sa théorie des marchés
du risque et de l'efficacité maximale a
longtemps déplu aux anti libéraux
beaucoup de gens étaient contre moi dans
le passé et pour une grande part parce
que je défends des défis que lui verse
c'est incroyable parce qu'aujourd'hui
parti socialiste des idées très voisines
de celles que j'ai défendu après la
guerre j'ai été impressionné par un
voyage aux etats unis
de l'apprendre la grande dépression et
donc j'ai travaillé l'économie pour pour
pour essayer de comprendre et bien la
transformation des conditions
matérielles de la vie en particulier
pour les gens modestes en france et est
quelque chose d'incroyable fantastique
ça c'est l'événement majeur
et aujourd'hui comment vous analysé la
situation le monde ne pourra pas
continuer avec les montagnes de dettes
qu'ils accumulent et avec le fait qu'on
peut pays qu'on peut acheter sans payer
qu'on peut acheter sans payer ça c'est
très grave comment on dit volontiers
quand on n'est pas prix nobel on ne peut
pas avoir le beurre et l'argent du
beurre l'argent de la drogue maintenant
avec la découverte en plein paris d'un
laboratoire de transformation de cocaïne
policiers et douaniers travaillant
ensemble ont interpellé neuf personnes
hier et met ainsi la main pour la
deuxième fois seulement sur un
dispositif exceptionnel de militaires
elle n'a pas eu le temps de servir la
panoplie du parfait chimiste tout était
là pourtant pour transformer cette pâte
de coca en poudre blanche
tout est parti de ses albums de photos
envoyées par la poste de colombie leur
poids 750 grammes chacun plusieurs
destinataires mais un seul expéditeurs
les postiers flers l'andouille discrète
filature et voici nos policiers aux 27
de la rue simard quatrième étage droite
roland bédié 48 ans et sa compagne l'élu
entreposés déjà chez eux plus de 2 kg de
pâte de cocaïne il étendait le nouvel
arrivage pour se mettre au travail dans
leur appartement
c'est la première fois que nous
découvrons à paris un matériel tout à
fait complet avec les produits chimiques
indispensables pour procéder à la
transformation de cette pâte de coca en
chlorhydrate c'est à dire la fameuse
neige qui fait encourir en ce moment
coup double pour les policiers banier
était recherché pour meurtre depuis 1981
huit autres complices sont sous les
verrous
autre coup de filet sur la côte d'azur
onze personnes inculpées plus de six
kilos d'héroïne rose saisis
c'est tout un réseau de trafiquants qui
étaient démantelés ils sont repartis
tranquillement chez eux
puis après avoir comparu à l'ouverture
de leur propre procès hier à bruxelles
les supporters britanniques qui avaient
déclenché les bagarres sanglantes de et
elles ne doivent pas assisté aux débats
qui vont être longs ils n'étaient plus
que huit sur 24 ce matin dans le box des
accusés
a bordeaux la cour d'assises spéciale
qui doit juger du sort de deux
dirigeants présumés de l'ex flnc accusé
d'assassinât a entendu aujourd'hui l'un
des ténors du mouvement nationaliste
corse
emmanuel vanier après les démêlés de
procédurière véritable début aujourd'hui
du procès à bordeaux des deux militants
de l'ex flnc accusé d'avoir tué un
légionnaire en 82 à la barre de témoin
de moralité cité par la défense de
figure du nationalisme corse
léo battesti et edmond simeoni qui ont
tenté de placer ce procès sur le terrain
politique
les deux hommes ont rappelé que pour
l'ex flnc qui poursuit une trêve des
attentats depuis quatre mois le verdict
aura valeur de test est certain que la
communauté corse est trop politisés pour
ne pas comprendre que le moindre aux
abords dow haier et dénaturent
compromettent la paix publique
edmond simeoni a lancé un appel à la
paix est la fraternité retrouvée verdict
de ce procès vendredi prochain
accord entre les états unis et les
philippines sur le maintien des deux
plus grandes bases américaines à
l'étranger
basa et terry aérienne à clark et navale
a subi qu dix sept mille militaires
america's passionneront tâches et aux
philippines jusqu'en 1991 importance
fondamentale pour les états unis
ces deux bases leur permettent le
contrôle et l'asie du sud-est et les
lignes maritimes de communication du
pacifique jusqu'aux boys compensations
financières versées par les états unis
multiplié par trois près de 3 milliards
de francs par an l'avenir des deux bases
n'est pas pour autant réglé d'ici à 1991
manille washington devront renégocier
leurs traités de défense et décider ou
non du renouvellement du bail pour ces
deux bases
onze émissaires soviétique aux etats
unis ils sont venus assister à la
destruction demain de 41 missiles de
croisière et de leurs lanceurs
américains et soviétiques poursuivre
ainsi l'élimination des missiles décidé
lors du traité a gagné gorbatchev de
juin dernier un émissaire américain
cette fois en union soviétique
mickey sur la place rouge sur le premier
festival oasis né à moscou pénurie de
piquer 12 heures d'attenté pour obtenir
une place mais les soviétiques ont
applaudi cette invasion de la souris
américaine à témoignages alarmants sur
les conséquences des émeutes algériennes
celui du docteur vernant de
l'organisation aux médecins du monde qui
revient d'algérie l'accès des hôpitaux
algériens est interdit aux médecins
étrangers et il ya tellement de victimes
qu'il est impossible de les
comptabiliser l'immense majorité des
morts sont des enfants et des
adolescents dont les corps n'ont pas
tous été rendus à leur famille dit ce
médecin à naplouse dans les territoires
occupés par israël un petit palestinien
de cinq ans est mort aujourd'hui après
avoir reçu trois balles dans la poitrine
un autre palestinien a été tué deux
autres personnes blessées dont un
journaliste américain
la visite est historique elle n'est pas
sans intérêt politique pour la première
fois en tout cas depuis hier un
souverain britannique est en visite
d'état en espagne
et quand une reine rencontre un roi qui
d'autre peut raconter l'histoire sur
antenne 2 remplissons pour tous les
amateurs de têtes couronnées
elisabeth winsor man batten reine
d'angleterre et de bien d'autres
contrées rend visite à son cousin juan
carlos de bourbon roi d'espagne en
termes de siècle de dynastie le diadème
d'or et pourquoi de carlos mais en
termes de scoop il revient sans conteste
à elisabeth qui enterre définitivement
le temps de la dictature décidément
shocking de franco
ces embrassades sont sincères et les
abbés terre brune carlos son cousin par
l'ancienne reine génie ils sont les
arrières petits-enfants de victoria il y
eut certes un mariage aussi à tort entre
philippe ii et marie la sanglante mais
cela s'est plutôt mal fini avec les
navires de la massive l'armada naufragés
en mer du nord par une autre elizabeth
ii grande mémoire
tout cela est désormais oubliée pour ces
deux souverains qui ont resserré leurs
liens personnels depuis que charles et
diana ont fait l'été dernier la
croisière de l'amour retrouvé sur le
yacht de juan carlos
reste un petit rien juste une petite
pierre dans ce jardin qui refleurit le
rocher de gibraltar
on laisse le soin de le faire sauter aux
politiques mais attention il faut s'y
prendre avec un flegme tout britannique
un autre souverain à 100 du maroc
n'attend que cela pour réclamer juan
carlos et de buthiers gibraltar
personnel ceuta et mellila enclaves
espagnoles dans le royaume chérifien
vous reconnais bien sûr notre ami
frédéric mitterrand qui vous donnent
rendez vous tout à l'heure à 00h20 comme
tous les jours pour revoir
du côté de chez fred il a osé ils ont
osé il y à une heure à londres au royal
festival hall les amateurs de beethoven
ont entendu pour la première fois le
premier mouvement d'une dixième
symphonie que l'immense compositeur
avait encore moins haché collet 9e
philippe harrouard nous en dit plus
legrand ludwig était là pour entendre le
premier mouvement de la symphonie qu'il
n'a jamais composé
responsable le docteur barry cooper
musicologue de l'université d'aberdeen
qui s'est inspiré des stif d'une dixième
symphonie de beethoven pour composer un
mouvement entier à la manière du maître
pour monsieur cooper il y à un tiers de
pétole et deux tiers de women mais il
est persuadé que s'il est un écoutez
cette oeuvre
il se retrouverait en terrain de
connaissance c'est aussi l'avis de
yehudi menuhin mais entendu su persuader
prouvé que même que ce n'est pas écrit
maps et son génie ça n'est pas composé
papito aussi l'homme
c'est vraiment une oeuvre authentique
mais comme il n'ya pas de on ne peut pas
durer je crois pas le directeur de la
maison des tops à bonn en allemagne lui
n'est pas content c'est du barry cooper
pas du béton at il déclaré en tout cas
ici à londres
on associe volontiers les deux noms et
on juge cet événement musical curieux et
sérieux
je reçois à l'instant l'ordre d'arrivée
à vincennes du trc qui vient de
secourisme le 11 le 4 et le 16 je n'ai
pas encore les rapports mais henri
sannier voulait donnera bien sûr dans
notre dernière édition du journal à
23h45 demain 6h45 roger zabel et dans un
instant j'osais blanc lapierre qui va
nous parler du temps jusqu'en alaska où
il s'agit de sauver trois baleines
grises prisonnière des glaces merci
d'avoir suivi ce journal à demain 20
heures